hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Meinung
Wanne und ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich
zu einem neuen Adventskalender auspack
Video wir sind langsam in der Zielgerade
es kommen nächste Woche noch zwei
Adventskalender am Dienstag und am
Donnerstag und am Sonntag kommt schon
die erste Block ist Folge
[Applaus]
falls einer von euch nicht weiß was
blocken es ist jedes Jahr versuche ich
aufs Neue meine Weihnachtszeit zu
dokumentieren und in Vlogs zu packen mal
erfolgreicher und mal ein bisschen
weniger erfolgreich
aber es macht jedes Jahr wieder Spaß und
ich bin motiviert ich weiß nicht hatte
noch nie so ein Energie Level Ende
November deswegen vielleicht wird es
dieses Jahr was ich werde es aber auf
jeden Fall abspecken ich versuche nicht
jeden Tag ein Video hochzuladen weil das
ist wirklich
und bevor wir jetzt anfangen schreibt
mir bitte in die Kommentare wie toll
meine Haare aussehen ich habe so
haar-komplexe ich kriege ich weiß auch
nicht meine Haare sind zur Zeit nicht
lang und nicht kurz und ich versuche sie
zu stylen und ist ich habe sie mir einen
Korea kurz geschnitten aber jetzt hätte
ich gerne gerade wieder so lange Haare
und wenn man nicht gerade 1500 € für
Extensions ausgeben möchte dann heißt es
warten ungefähr drei Jahre so ich werde
aber auch zu labern heute ist ja
nineties Adventskalender von Randa and
the gang dran ich weiß nicht wer Randa
and Gang ist ich habe nur gesehen dass
das 90er Jahre Adventskalender ist und
da habe ich gedacht mensch das ist doch
mal was Neues was cooles aber wir finden
gemeinsam in diesem Video heraus wer
anders
gespannt meine liebe liebe
was die Spice Girls 1996 wirklich
wollten werden wir wohl nie erfahren
aber was ich will das weiß ich dieses
Jahr in der Adventszeit gemeinsam mit
euch eine Zeitreise in die 90er Jahre zu
erleben ja man die 90er Jahre haben uns
geprägt uns neben der besten Musik auch
viel Freude und Farbe gebracht und genau
das möchte ich mit diesem
Adventskalender zurück in euer Leben
bringen cooles Konzept viel Spaß beim
Auspacken eure Rander Scheiße die hat
voll den coolen Jeanslook an sieht voll
cool aus sie sieht voll nineties aus ich
nein dies aus nein ich habe ein blödes
Lulu lemon-oberteil an 1993 hat mich
meine Mama aus ihrer
Tür gebracht und ich habe das Licht der
Welt entdeckt und es war wunderbar ich
erinnere mich noch ganz genau an den Tag
aber es geht ja hier nicht um mich
sondern um Randa
[Musik]
Thunder ans Mikro proud mom of two girls
one baby boy sie kommt auch aus Berlin
meine Nachbarin wanderweiser boah die
hat aber viele Follower du
und da wird wirklich wie eine sehr nette
Person das einzige ist halt dass ich
immer nicht ganz mag wenn Eltern ihre
Kinder zeigen aber ich muss auch da an
der Stelle sagen ich kann darüber auch
noch nicht so ganz judgen weil ich nicht
selber Mutter bin naja das ist hier ja
aber kein Familienkalender sondern ein
likes Kalender deswegen lassen wir mal
wann das Entscheidungen über ihre
Familie ihre Entscheidung sein und ich
dachte dass man vielleicht irgendwas zum
Hersteller findet aber nein
der Kalender kostet 49 Euro 95 ist ein
guter Preis finde ich für ein
Adventskalender ist noch so in der
oberen Grenze zu kann man machen alle
anderen die sehr viel mehr Geld kosten
sind halt dann eine wirkliche
Investition und ja dann muss man halt
doppelt und dreifach darüber denken
nachdenken aber 50 € finde ich es okay
in jedem Typen steckt ganz viel Liebe
viele
Monate nicht alle Produkte getestet
genascht gespielt und einen Flashback
nach dem anderen gehabt der Inhalte
Adventskalender aber wer hat den gemacht
habt ihr den selber gemacht wie geht das
ich bin gerade ein bisschen verwirrt
weil ich nicht weiß wer den jetzt
wirklich am Ende produziert hat aber
vielleicht haben sie es wirklich einfach
selber gemacht und dann finde ich das
ganz schön beeindruckend weil ich ja
auch darüber nachdenke Adventskalender
rauszubringen ich würde das aber nie
alleine machen wollen weil das ist
wirklich sehr sehr viel Arbeit und jetzt
lasst uns in die nineties surfen da wo
ist das Internet schon gab aber lange
noch nicht so wie heute
nice Türchen ach so
sorry einmal zum Design Hammer also
wirklich sehr sehr cute es wackelt da
drin alles ein bisschen rum da muss man
vorsichtig sein aber das Design ist
wirklich genauso möchte man das ne das
ist normal
eins okay Nummer eins ja was ist das
eigentlich also ich kenne es auf jeden
Fall aus meiner Kindheit jetzt kann ich
mir aber auch vorstellen in was für eine
Richtung dieser Kalender gehen wird und
das da bin ich jetzt gespannt ob er
überzeugt oder ob es naja wir gucken
jetzt mal ich mag auf jeden Fall dieses
Prinzip vom Kalender öffnen natürlich
sind wieder verwendbare auch super aber
das ist so dieses Original Gefühl von
dem Kalender und er ist komplett aus
Pappe also drin ist kein Plastik im
Türchen Nummer oha in Türchen Nummer
zwei
das ist das gleiche Prinzip das gibt's
hier auch das werde ich jetzt nicht
probieren sondern in die verlosungsbox
reinpacken das ist das gleiche Prinzip
wie dieses oh ich glaube das ist die
Süßigkeit aus Mexiko ist in einem Ding
so ein Stick gibt und hier sind so
Pulver drin und dann kannst du
reinpulver und das dann abschlecken ich
finde es komisch da bin ich mal gespannt
was eine so eine Packung kostet 24 Cent
wollen wir notieren mal was wir denken
was dieser Kalender dann gekauft hat und
so wir machen
gibt es wir machen es ich hätte jetzt
eigentlich gesagt bei solchen Dingern da
würde ich jetzt 50 Cent sagen ähm für
dich das eigentlich nicht machen wollen
weil da muss man ja auch am Ende ja komm
wir machen einfach mal weiter
okay okay schlecken Muscheln klar das
ist typisch 90er kann mich erinnern dass
die gar nicht so lecker waren
die schmeckt nach Orange wir bleiben
gleich mal World of Sweets ich denke mal
wir werden da viel finden schlecken
Muscheln ich bin mal gespannt was wir
hier so für Preise zusammen kriegen 8,95
€ durch 50 x 2,5
Nummer 4
das ist ein Erlebnis Adventskalender
hier kriegt man wirklich Flashback
obwohl die sind zwar 90er ne aber die
sind schon längst wieder zurückgekommen
das ist die hier 12 peace Joker
Halskette Set Henna Tattoos Stretch
blablabla 70 Cent ja ich fühle mich
jetzt komplett in die 90er
zurückversetzt was ist ein Türchen
Nummer 5 drin
wow ich wusste nicht dass das typisch
90er ist ich dachte das ist typisch
Polen ich brauche eins für mein
Assistent Kanal ich weiß noch dass mein
Onkel mir mal so einen bei der
Tankstelle gekauft hat und ich war so
happy natürlich war es ein anderes Motiv
ich mache gerade Low Carb und deswegen
ist mir glaube ich alles gerade super
lecker aber die schleckmuschel ist
besser ist ein bisschen schwierig ne
kann man so Lollies einfach ohne
Zutatenliste ohne irgendwas in so einem
Kalender packen hier ist ja keine Liste
also hier ist absolut keine Info darüber
was dann da drin ist weil sie nicht
dicker hier bei den einzelnen da sieht
man das 50 Cent für die 20 Türchen
Nummer 6 das ist ein Kalender für
moment mal ich mache gerade Low Carb
warum esse ich den Zucker Zucker ist
doch auch kam Nummer sechs Nikolaus mal
gucken was dran bei uns da reingepackt
hat okay hier ist auf jeden Fall ein
Nikolaus special drin oh mein Gott wieso
wieso gabs die jemals warum haben wir
das getan was war das für eine Zeit
hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure Meinung
wie vorsichtig mein Nachbar bohrt ich
höre richtig wieder versucht so ganz
langsam und Dings machst du jetzt
einfach schnell ungefähr ich sag 5 €,
ich muss man halt sagen ne das ist cool
Kinder hat ist das cool auch wenn ich
90er Jahre Fan bin wüsste ich jetzt
nicht was mache ich mit dieser Figur
verschenken und ein Kind verstören aber
es war zu Nikolaus was besonderes und
das appreciate ich okay weiter geht's 7
nein Magic Garden mit Pop Rock das ist
so cool
ist so Kniff dann im Mund
mhmm
knisternde Zuckerware mit Kaugummi der
Kaugummi hängt mir jetzt einfach nur
zwischen den Zehen
[Applaus]
das tut aber schon teilweise weh ne aber
jetzt können wir Hit und absoluter
Klassiker der 90er Jahre 26
Nummer 8 laufe jetzt ja also Kaugummi
nach Kaugummi finde ich jetzt nicht die
beste Entscheidung nee lass mal meine
Kinderherz schreit gerade einfach hören
ne schon damals so schwer das
rauszukriegen
kleine Kinder noch viel mehr dran
arbeiten
ich mag auch Kirschgeschmack das ist
Kirschgeschmack also die Qualität des
Kaugummis ist schrecklich ich habe das
Gefühl ich kann es gleich
runterschlucken weil ich es heute
flüssig ist 69 Cent wenn man es in Masse
kauft dann wird es noch günstiger aber
ich sehe jetzt für uns jetzt kommt das
beste natürlich in aller Zeiten Türchen
Nummer 9 und darin befindet sich
[Musik]
ne weiß leider nicht wofür das ist ich
sag 50 Cent keine Ahnung wie das ist
finden soll Nummer 9 ist das jetzt
persönlich für mich nicht aber es ist
schon irgendwie cool also es hat schon
Spaß gemacht Nummer zehn
aus den 90ern schreibt sie jetzt gerne
in die Kommentare in Nummer zehn
ist der Geschmackstest
oh mein Gott das ist doch Karies amst
warum hat man das als Kind immer lecker
Lolli Flöte 29 Cent okay
Nummer 11 und ich glaube jetzt hier
wieder was zum spielen drin
oh ja volo
da muss Wasser rein 12 Sekunden später
kommen Euro
ich bin ich bin ich bin zurück ich bin
zurück in meiner Kindheit oh mein Gott
Center shocks saura Apfel habe ich nie
ertragen können oh es tut jetzt schon
weh okay Wurst
[Musik]
als Kind wo war das der Hammer es gab
nichts was cooler war außer vielleicht
noch Pokémon Karten aber das hm 5 Cent
wenn jetzt sagt aber wann ist er das
sind doch einfach nur alles diese
komischen Gewinne die man beim Jahrmarkt
oder Weihnachtsmarkt bekommt wenn man
eine Niete ist ja das ist absolutes
Jahrmarkt China Plastikzeug wie viele
von diesen Dingern in meinem
Kinderzimmer verflucht rumlagen und ich
hoffe damit habe ich euch jetzt so eine
Kindheitserinnerung rausgeholt diese
verstaubten Teile im Zimmer
Hammer heutzutage hängen wir den ganzen
Tag auf tiktok rum und Social Media und
sumieren einfach nur noch das hängt auch
an der Wand
oh mein Gott das ist cool ich bin
Spider-Man
ich bin Spider-Man
ich war Spider-Man Scheiße 30 Cent
natürliche Nummer 14 schon wieder
Kaugummi aber diesmal Tattoo Kaugummi es
könnte auch der große nineties Kaugummi
Adventskalender sein
[Musik]
einmal den Geschmack von meinen
Schulranzen auf und auch gerade zu den
Weg
was Geschmäcker mit einem machen können
ich glaube wenn ich den Geschmack heute
das allererste Mal schmecken würde würde
ich sagen boah was sind das für ein
Kaugummi das schmeckt er gar nicht
lecker aber das Knistern einfach in
meinem Hirn und ganz viele Erinnerungen
und Gefühle kommen gerade voll auf ich
weiß das klingt total übertrieben aber
es ist so wenn man wenn ich das alles
hier schmecke dann dann schmecke ich
einfach meine Kindheit so aber das
Besondere an diesem Kaugummis ist nicht
der Geschmack sondern
das Tattoo im monatlich ständig Karies
hatte ein arschgewei klebt jetzt unter
hier unter meinem
es geht aber ohne Wasser das ist nicht
so ein Tattoo was man nass macht sondern
einfach so halten muss
cool cool cool cool cool
die Hälfte ist nicht mitgekommen ja toll
das ist diese Firma aber auch noch gibt
ne dass sie weiterhin produzieren das
macht bestimmt richtig Spaß in so einer
Firma zu arbeiten wo du weißt eigentlich
seid ihr nicht mehr der heiße Scheiß
aber die Leute kaufen es trotzdem noch
weil sie in Erinnerung schwelgen wollen
400 Stück 11,99 €
6 Cent 5 10
und jetzt kommt auch versuchte richtig
schnell so richtig verstanden also
[Musik]
das ist er doch das ist er wird so ein
Stück für 8,99 30 Stück für 12 89 das
ist ja 42 Cent
16 Klassiker oh das sind aber nicht die
mit dem pink drin
die Kette schmeckt aber leider nicht wie
die gute Sorte es gibt noch eine
hübschere Kette mit pink und blau
dazwischen ich schreib mal 20 Cent auf
Nummer 17 das
war sowas und dann hat man sich das
Bändchen weitergegeben und dann musste
man das so rausnehmen habt ihr das auch
in der Schule gespielt musste man sich
das so umlegen also wahrscheinlich nicht
na ja und dann hat der andere das
rausgenommen und musste das irgendwie in
seine Hand wieder festmachen und dann
hat man das wieder rausgeholt
oh gott ist das ein Flashback schreibt
man 20 Cent auf Nummer 18 unser Kalender
ist jetzt volljährig und es geht wieder
was zum snacken also die Abwechslung
zwischen Snacks und Spielsachen finde
ich gut das fällt mir sehr positiv auf
die Candy Lipstick klar
vergess Klinik oder sonst was leider das
ist der heiße Scheiß der Candy Lipstick
der schmeckt nicht 14 Cent 19
was könnte es anderes sein als ein Jojo
es gibt so richtig
ich habe das Gefühl die Spielzeuge
früher sollten einfach nur die
Hyperaktivität der Kinder beruhigen klar
Sonja ne
Jojo wie lange ich nicht darüber
nachgedacht habe über so ein Jojo es
gibt so Profi Jojos wow gar nicht mehr
so eine gute Bewertung finde ich auch
der ist komisch also die 99 durch
15,50 € wir sind in den 20ern angekommen
ja ich glaube Low Carb kann ich heute
wirklich vergessen die Nippon waren als
Kind meine
absoluten Liebling ich weiß ich sag das
bei allen Sachen und ihr glaubt mir das
nicht wirklich aber doch lieber meine
lieblings
innen drin ist so ein festes Schaum
Karamell Zeug was sind die lecker schon
Laktose oder sowas zu essen
sind die Reis Dinger Nappo
toll die werden kiloweise verkaufen
21 heute brauche sogar definitiv zu den
90ern dazu aber
am besten prickelt auf der Zunge
10 Cent 22 muss sein ein absoluter
Klassiker vielleicht lerne ich es ja
noch mal das haben schon etliche Leute
versucht mir zu erklären wie das hier
mit diesem Rubik's Cube funktioniert
keine Chance
23 unser vorletztes Türchen wir haben
schon einen kleinen Zuckerschock
bekommen und hier ist Nachschub ich
meine das ist zwar 90er aber das sehe
ich zum Beispiel bei Müller immer wieder
ne also dieser Fuß der imports
reingetippt
wie mein Hirn richtig so ist Soka
50 Cent nee ab 48 Stück 30 sind und
jetzt kommt das letzte Türchen
Weihnachten wir sind gespannt und ist es
etwa na klar was wären die 90er Jahre
ohne unsere Tamagotchis gewesen das
Leben beginnt wenn man eine Lasche zieht
lass uns ihn zum Leben erwecken
man kann sich ein Tier aussuchen
völlig überzuckert ja aber hallo das
kostet gut ah das ist nicht der echte
Tamagotchi der echte Tamagotchi wird
jetzt noch 22 € verkauft dieser
Tamagotchi mach mir 350 boah jetzt will
ich einen echten Tamagotchi jetzt habe
ich es ist naja gut ähm das ist alles äh
ich werde jetzt mal die Preise
zusammenrechnen und dann gucken wir
einfach mal oder ja super Klasse äh ich
habe jetzt sehr großzügige 17 52 raus
32,43 Euro also wenn man die Ausgaben
für die Sachen zählt nehmen Sie ungefähr
35 Euro ein davon muss man den Versand
bezahlen oder habe ich den Versand
bezahlt okay davon muss man den Versand
bezahlen davon muss man die Verpackung
bezahlen Versand und Verpackung macht
sie ungefähr 20 € plus Kalender ich bin
ein bisschen hin und hergerissen weil
ich die Arbeit dahinter verstehe und mir
denke klar da können jetzt keine Türchen
für 2 € drin sein dann die meisten
Türchen haben Wert von unter 30 Cent
oder oder ja also 10 Cent teilweise und
jetzt mal nicht darauf bezogen ob man
was für sein Geld kriegt und wie viel
und so ich finde die experience nice
also es macht wirklich Spaß und Jojo
rauszuholen und dann damit kurz zu
spielen und so teilweise finde ich aber
finde ich es nicht ganz berechtigt warum
sollte ich jetzt also ein Ding haben
also für wen ist dieser Kalender gemacht
ich bin jetzt 30 und habe halt Spaß ist
zweimal die Wand zu klatschen aber jetzt
auch nicht als kinderkalender deklariert
bei den Süßigkeiten kann ich irgendwie
noch verstehen obwohl die Süßigkeiten
auch alle sehr es ist ich weiß also ich
finde den Kalender schon cool und ich
finde auch dass man nicht es so
abrechnen sollte dass es halt eins zu
eins passt mit dem was man ausgegeben
hat und dass man genauso viel wieder
rein kriegt darum geht es nicht ich
meine Rande hat sich da Gedanken
zugemacht sie hat die Sachen ausgesucht
ähm geschaut das ist schön zusammenpasst
auch wenn es ein bisschen viel Lollis
und ist aber andererseits haben mich
auch über die Sachen gefreut dadurch
dass das alles so günstig ist weiß ich
nicht ob sie nicht lieber mit World of
Sweets oder so zusammen hätte arbeiten
sollen dass sie unter 30 € für diesen
Kalender kommt weil die experience ist
an sich nice aber sie ist nicht 50 €
nice die ist so 25 bis 30 € nice weil
der Inhalt wirklich nicht viel ist ne
und ich habe sogar noch Preise gerechnet
da hat also das sind noch ganz also also
ich kann wahrscheinlich noch viel zu
gute Preise gerechnet jetzt vielleicht
für den Inhalt 10 € ausgegeben aber das
sind alles im spielkulation deswegen
will ich auch jetzt gar nicht so viel
sagen aber ich weiß auch nicht der
Kalender der Spaß gemacht aber irgendwie
sind 50 € komisch gleichzeitig dann
lieber nur ein nineties Snacks
Adventskalender gut gefunden auch wenn
ich mich über das Fake Tamagotchi und
Jojo gefreut habe na ich weiß es nicht
auf jeden Fall cool dass sie sich das
getraut hat ja das ist mein Fazit
tschüssi schreibt mir gerne mal eure
Gedanken zu dem Kalender versteht ihr
was ich meine dieses hin und hergerissen
aber ja für 50 €, keine Ahnung das ist
halt jahrmarktzeug ne sag mal auch nicht
vergessen das kriegt man auf einem
Jahrmarkt auch wenn nein ich weiß es
nicht tschüss